now here's the deal uh you need to know
a couple things about jacob first of all
no matter where he is it's the best
place he's ever been
it's such a cool attitude to have that
dude does it not
he doesn't know how to have a bad time
he's he and not only that
if i sat him down at any of your tables
he could talk to you all for an hour
seamlessly and you'd be like man i've
known this dude for a decade
he's also the dumbest of my three kids
no he's not dumb like i'm not saying
he's dumb
everybody but who's got kids in here
who's that kid do you have multiple kids
okay saying you got a dumb one too do
you know what i mean like here's the
deal
if you if you have more than one kid
you've got a dumb one
i'm not saying your kid is dumb but
compared to the other ones
that's the dumb one you know what i mean
and if you have more than one kid do you
have more than one kid
i'm telling you right now you this one
okay let me tell you something
they've had this conversation in their
room before
what the [ __ ] are we gonna do with the
dumb one
are we gonna let him out by himself he's
so [ __ ] stupid i don't know what to
do
[Applause]
that hit a little too close to home over
at this table here all right
so all right he was six years old
and my buddy called and said hey we'd
like jacob to be the ring bearer at the
wedding
and i was like great jacob had always
wanted to wear a tux
so i go hey man you get to be the ring
bearer and he was like do i
can i wear tuts can i go yeah and he
goes white talks i like
sure and he goes top hat i go nut
and on the way out of the room he says
well i guess i can't get a cane then i
was like what
what shows are you watching dude what is
going on right
so we go to the wedding now look those
of you with kids know that age at six
that's still that pure joy age and you
know when
your kid is gonna be that happy that
pure joy on their face i want to be
up close to see it because you know it
doesn't happen
forever you know so i'm sitting in the
pew and i'm by the aisle and
he comes to the church doors and he's in
his white tux
and he's got his rings in this hand and
he's walking down the aisle and with
this hand he's going like this
and i was like
what is the dumb one doing
and i go come here buddy come here what
are you doing
and he goes i'm the i'm the ring bearer
i go
oh the ring bear and he goes yeah and it
wasn't my wedding i was like well you're
doing a great job keep going
he walked around the whole wedding guys
my friend was like what is your dumpkin
[Music]
doing
[Music]
[Music]
foreign